c'était pour faire comme à la télé ce
sont les premières explications données
par les deux accusés ce soir une
déclaration qui laisse l'assistance sans
voix mais la journée a d'abord été
marquée par l'analyse des circonstances
du drame les experts expliquent que le
local poubelles étaient situés bien trop
près du mur du foyer que le renfoncement
de la façade a provoqué un effet
cheminée et que ce soir là les rafales
de vent ont rabattu les fumées contre le
bâtiment toutes les parties mettent en
avant cette conjonction de paramètres
cette conjonction là qui à partir de 2 2
d'un briquet a entraîné un drame de
cette proportion et les interrogations
sont là alors elle met en cause bien
évidemment parce que quand on pose une
question on peut mettre en cause
effectivement des responsables ou des
responsabilités mais ce n'est pas le
procès du notre responsabilité
aujourd'hui que celle des deux incendies
le matériau isolant de la façade est
également mis en cause le polystyrène
étant très inflammable et dégageant des
fumées toxiques
les experts précisent également que le
système d' alerte incendie et
d'évacuation des fumées daté de la fin
des années 80 oui mais voilà toutes ses
installations respectaient les normes
européennes de sécurité
sait-on jamais peut-être que ce procès
va pouvoir permettre d'alerter les
pouvoirs publics sur la nécessité de
revoir un petit peu leur copie ou les
copies en général de toute façon sur les
normes de sécurité pour les immeubles à
usage d'habitation passe quand on
s'expose véritablement à ce que ce drame
se reproduise lors de ces débats nous
avons également retenu qu aucune
réglementation n'existe concernant un
local poubelle d'habitations collectives
lors de ce deuxième jour d'audience
plutôt que de mettre en cause les deux
accusés ce sont plutôt les
réglementations en matière d' incendies
qui ont été pointés du doigt